histórica demanda contra una de las
empresas más grandes del mundo
bienvenidos a economía a quién france24
y para analizar esta y otras noticias
tenemos a la especialista económica
daniela blandón ramírez daniela muy
bienvenida cuáles son los argumentos
clave que llevaron a eeuu a demandar a
google bueno pues el departamento de
justicia presentó la demanda
antimonopolio más grande de casi dos
décadas la última había sido contra
microsoft entre otras cosas alega que
google usa su poder y millonarias
ganancias para bloquear a rivales como
bing y yahoo entre otros dice también
que les paga a firmas como apple y
samsung para que su aplicación esté
predeterminada en su teléfono y en mi
teléfono
alan y no es para menos entre ocho y
nueve de cada diez búsquedas mundiales
por internet son por google y esto hace
imposible la misión de montar la
competencia
google es la puerta de entrada a
internet gigante de la publicidad basada
en búsquedas la empresa logró cierto
éxito en sus primeros años y nadie lo
lamenta pero como explica la demanda
antimonopolio presentada hoy ha
mantenido su poder de monopolio a través
de tácticas de exclusión que son dañinas
a la competencia hay que decir que la
empresa se defendió diciendo que el que
usa google es porque quiere y no porque
lo obliga vámonos a colombia y es que
parece que al fin la capital bogotá
tendría metro daniela por lo menos hoy
se firmó el acta de inicio de
construcción de este sistema
el constructor es un consorcio chino que
ha sido muy polémico porque cuando ganó
la licitación se conoció que tuvo
problemas en la ejecución de varios de
sus proyectos alrededor del mundo la
primera línea del metro cuesta casi tres
mil cuatrocientos millones de dólares de
los cuales la nación aportará el 70 por
ciento serán en total 23 9 kilómetros
por los que se transportarán más de un
millón de pasajeros por día pero no ya
sino en el segundo trimestre de 2028 los
cálculos del gobierno apuntan a que se
crearán unos 17.000 empleos entre
e indirectos y si efectivamente se
construye bogotá dejará por fin de ser
la única gran ciudad latinoamericana sin
metro oye daniela netflix no le fue muy
bien en este tercer trimestre pues mire
el gigante de servicio de streaming
agregó en este periodo una no
despreciable cantidad de 2.2 millones de
usuarios esta es la más baja en cuatro
años pues cuando empezó la pandemia
netflix tuvo casi 16 millones de
suscriptores y eso le hizo pensar que
los siguientes trimestres serían no
iguales pero sí mucho mejores en el
segundo trimestre agregó 10 como 1
millones de usuarios pero la cifra cayó
dramáticamente esto se debió a la
competencia de empresas como disney y
warner y la transmisión de deportes en
vivo que se reanudó en el mundo lo que
sí aumentó fueron sus ingresos en 22%
pero eso no impidió que sus acciones en
wall street cayera en un 6 por ciento
ahora explíquenos esta noticia daniela
en palestina las enfrenta a la escasez
de energía con aceitunas mira lo
interesante de esta historia alan y es
que la zona conocida como la franja de
gaza que es el hogar de 2 millones
ha estado bajo un bloqueo de egipto e
israel desde que el grupo militante
hamas tomó el poder en 2007
allí la mitad de las personas no tiene
empleo y la energía llega apenas unas
horas al día por estos días es temporada
de aceitunas en palestina y un grupo de
ingenieros aprovechan los residuos que
quedan después de que se elabora el
aceite de oliva se trata de las pepas y
en general de lo que queda de la
aceituna y hacen en combustible
comprimido conocido como pelets estos se
utilizan en granjas avícolas por mujeres
que usan hornos de barro en casa o en
talleres de alimentación y pastelería
cuando se queman duran mucho tiempo y
producen mucho calor también es barato
en comparación con el petróleo y el gas
de cocción en efecto a la no una
tonelada de este combustible se vende a
100 dólares y una tonelada de madera a
200 dólares el doble a muy bien vamos
con los indicadores económicos del día o
streeter sigue esperanzado en que habrá
un paquete de ayudas antes de elecciones
y por eso cerró en positivo en europa
hubo resultados dispares en medio de la
incertidumbre sobre nuevas vacunas
y de las discusiones por el break sit y
en américa latina' buen repunte de las
principales plazas bursátiles en
especial el sao paulo que sigue los
pasos de wall street- cerramos con la
cifra el día bueno sabía usted que hoy
es el día mundial de la estadística no
es sin estadística ni siquiera crónica
económica tendríamos nosotros y para
conmemorarlo eurostat reveló que hay 93
mil matemáticos y estadísticos en los 27
países de la unión europea
esto representa apenas el 0 05 por
ciento del empleo total en estos países
las felicidades por el día mundial de la
estadística daniela muchas gracias por
el recorrido económico y ustedes por su
compañía hacía con más en francés 24
[Música]